for my first time viewers my videos and
I are heavily associated with spider-man
both for my critiques on comics movies
and games featuring the character but
also my uncanny ability to cosplay the
all red and blue doofus but is my
longtime viewers and my slowly declining
analytics can tell you sometimes I get a
little bored of captain complainer in
his spandex clad crusade so if you'll
indulge me I'm finally doing a video on
one of my other cosplays in this case
the main hero of my favorite game of all
time Isaac Clark from dead space dead
space is the ultimate nostalgia trip for
me and I played it when it came out and
my little 10 year old self was scared to
death before the third level was over
but I just kept playing it I also played
a lot of it with my uncle and my dad my
first youtube videos ever when I was 11
years old and I made an animated sitcom
about dead space's protagonist living in
an apartment with Samus and Master Chief
go check those out if you want to see
some cringe slash godzilla mendoza
history i guess
here's later dead space was the first
game i got every single achievement in
and had played it beginning to end about
10 times by myself
in short i adored this game in this
unique bizarrely designed main character
but my cosplaying him this year was
rather spontaneous i didn't really plan
to make this suit for a long time or
anything it just kind of struck me one
day as i was out killing times that i
could probably do it if i wanted to so i
hit up the party store and got a plastic
construction helmet a black panther mask
and then I went to the Hobby Lobby next
door and bought a few stacks of really
thick craft foam the next night I had a
rather on model helmet because I'm very
impatient and I like working on things
when I'm depressed which is all the time
so I took a knife and strong-armed the
ears off the Black Panther mask then I
use the dremel tool to saw the brim off
the construction hat after taking the
straps out of it then I glued them
together with some chunks of foam in
between to help the glue grip better I
always use this gelled gorilla glue
because it's the strongest glue ever and
you can use it to attach wheels to a car
yeah and probably I just made that up
anyway I made a square shape of foam for
the faceplate then started drawing and
cutting foam in the shape of all these
dumb angular panels and plates on his
mask
before long I realized hey this actually
looks like the helmet so I refined it a
little added some foam to the sides to
cover more of the head then did that big
battery pack a looking thing on the back
of his head maybe about four hours I had
made something completely different from
anything I had ever done for cosplay
before usually I just stabbed my thumb a
thousand times or annoying my mother to
set up the sewing machine and make
spandex superhero costumes I've seen
tons of talented people make convincing
armor sets with lightweight materials
but I never really thought I was capable
of it
then I just kind of did it on accident
one night after I had all the tiny
little details on the helmet perfected
or at the very least close enough that
[ __ ] is on Instagram can't complain
about it I took it outside then started
spray-painting it with this magical
stuff called Plasti Dip
it's sort of a rubbery spray paint that
makes foam stronger and easier to paint
but also allows it to stay flexible it
also helps keep your spray paint from
eating away at the foam and it's
waterproof
it's neat stuff and I think you should
all keep a can of it in your cosplay
arsenal just don't breathe it in too
much because it'll give you drain Babich
and then you'll forgot talk words good
the plastidip stuff dries faster when
it's warm but I live in a state where
it's always snowing at night so I just
left it to sit in the garage and watch
his am then I came back outside and it
was all ready to paint again this time I
did it outside and in the daytime
because again very impatient I used
these waterproof spray paints that are
very metallic I went over it with a
layer of gold first to imply it was kind
of shiny and new at one point then again
with a rusty copper color to imply it
had been dropped down a flight of stairs
and spattered with oil and electrical
sparks once or twice by our intrepid MIT
graduate protagonists for the glass
inside of it I used some strips of
plastic covered in this sticker stuff
called perforated vinyl which is
surprisingly cheap come to think of it a
lot of the process for making this thing
was the same as making some spider-man
lenses looks like my skills in that area
can be applied somewhere else and all
the kids in middle school said my
spider-man lunchbox was stupid now look
where I am making a helmet and being
hugely in debt with student loans while
living with my parents and where are
they all at the exact same situation
without the helmet so fuck'em
but yeah here's a helmet and then I came
to the realization that I had enough
foam leftover that I could probably just
make a whole suit
so I bought a Grey's end tie online and
the rest was history except they
accidentally sent me two of them in the
mail one of which being one size too
small so I just rolled with it and opted
to have it be the outer layer of
material on his suit since his costume
looks like it has a lot of layers of
different materials and with this method
I didn't have to painstakingly recreated
his weird leather chaps to give the
outer suit more of a leathery feel and
to capture that icky brown color that
characterizes most of the games
aesthetic I used a brush and some Browns
slick puff paint to coat almost this
entire smaller suit it looks and feels
very different texture wise but it still
stretches and bends just like good old
spandex then I sewed it to the inner
suit and made them one glorious space
man's jumpsuit okay now this next part
is a little tedious there are so many
metal panels and plates all over the
suit layers so intricately that it all
starts to make it look like one big vest
I measured cut out plastidip and painted
all of them see these flimsy gray ones I
cut them out of gray foam plastidip
sprayed it then painted it gray again so
wouldn't air as easily this thinner foam
is as durable as paper unless you go
over all of that it's a pain but it's
worth it
once again my household remains 100%
mannequin free due to forces outside my
control so I painted and glued a lot of
this while it was on a pillow inside of
a trash bag the arms were a little more
difficult because I didn't have anything
to put inside them that fit so like the
genius I am I wrap myself in plastic
saran wrap and then glued the foam to
myself while I wore it fun fact this
glue heats up when it sticks to
something for the first time and if you
don't have a layer of plastic between
you and the suit
it can scald your skin and fuse the
fabric into your pores science is fun
and terrifying this suit quickly became
a bit of a deathtrap as cool as it looks
the foam paneling is all very solid and
hard to flex initially putting this
thing on for the first time took me
about 30 minutes because I was scared of
breaking something and the suit was so
averse to stretching and flexing the
third time I wore it and only took
eight minutes you gotta break it in so
to speak now for the numerous
accessories I think the most
intimidating part of this design for me
was the health bar on the back I know
this rig is one of the coolest sci fi
machines and video games but something
about it scared me
it had to light up and I have no idea
what I'm doing when it comes to wiring
lights and electricity and [ __ ] so I
enlisted the help of my dad a few of you
may remember him from that time I ate
spicy wings I had all of the materials
pretty much ready to go but was a lot of
stress figuring out how to combine them
I used a tube of plastic this row of
decorative lights that I strung through
the tube and various other things like
bottle caps and metal pieces to fill in
in places some of the mechanical details
I'm very proud of how heavily strung the
battery pack and the switch for the
lights through the suit while also being
accessible to turn it on and off that
meant that I had to attach it to the
back of the suit with a bit of a gap in
the middle so I used some snap buttons
with small columns of foam under it to
keep it raised up it came out pretty
okay save for the snap buttons getting
all mangled by the glue making the whole
thing not want to attack properly at the
convention a few of you historians on
the channel may know this isn't the
first time I caused played this
character let alone the first time I did
it at a convention remember that dead
space let's play no one watch neither do
I when I was about 13 my mom and dad and
uncle made this suit for me in a few
weeks leading up to Halloween it was
made out of a few layers of pleather
sweatpants a turtleneck shirt some denim
and a lot of thick foam carved by hand
in the shape of armor pieces all things
considered it came out pretty good
the lights were made from glow sticks
and plastic bottles that were melted
down and reshaped at the time we didn't
know that foam and spray paint didn't
get along so the styrofoam chips and
scratches and flakes off anytime I put
it on I also needed the help of like
three people to put this suit on and it
was insanely hot all the layers of foam
and fake leather and warm clothes made
this thing murder to wear on any summer
day after the only convention I took
this suit - I remember peeling out of it
covered in sweat and feeling
light-headed but hey at least the back
still lit up as much as it was a chore
to get on and off I still appreciate my
parents for putting it together for me
and my dad and uncle staying up all
night to figure out the helmet conundrum
on the day before Halloween so I'd have
something to wear their strategy was to
make it have a baseball cap in an old
Jason Voorhees mask which actually kind
of inspired the materials I chose for my
thing as a tribute to them I invested
the old suit in just about every way
particularly practicality then for this
oh yeah a stasis bar I don't get a light
into that [ __ ] it I don't know just
don't glue this part of the plate on the
back so it's kind of like a pocket and
then slide a glow stick in it dunzo BAM
oh well this other junk is just
accessories with a lot of craft foam
building really if you've made the rest
of the suits so far you're pretty good
at crafting metallic and mechanical
looking structures with foam and Gorilla
Glue so I'll let you just figure all
this out you're an adult now I can't
hold your hand through everything please
move out of my basement I need that
space to put my scraps of foam for
making this damn thing thanks you two
anyway the boots on the suit are rather
simple and plain looking the hardest
part is getting that rusty metal look I
used some old skating knee pads base and
just attach foam tubes to it then built
a shape for the knee to cover it up
plastidip and done well except for these
little robot II looking pieces that go
on there they make it look a little less
basic I suppose so just carve those out
paint them and then slap them on for my
boots I took an old pair of vans and
attached a silly amount of foam layers
to it until eventually it looked heavy
metal plated and clunky these boots were
made for stomping you see I realized the
suit looks pretty good but it kind of
feels empty without the laser tool to
dismember undead mutants with so I made
one of those in a total of three hours
I cut out a block of styrofoam in the
shape of a handle then attached more and
more foam to it until it stopped
chipping and leaving white dusty [ __ ]
everywhere thus began the trial of
finding anything in my house that looked
vaguely mechanical so I could glue it
onto this thing and make it look less
like a block of styrofoam I don't think
the stuff I used for the decoration on
this will be reproducible because this
stuff is very specific part of it is a
few panels from the casing of a broken
RC car some of it is straps from the
inside of the hard hat
to make the helmet and some of it is
casings from a defunct nuclear warhead
that still has trace amounts of
radiation absorbed into the alloy coated
and toxic rubber slime let it dry
graffiti it up real good like that
spider-man with the Jordans on and then
you got yourself a halfway decent prop
it's a good thing this design from the
game already has big orange highlights
on the tip so you won't be arrested for
taking this into a convention speaking
of I took this costume to a contest at
Denver pop culture con because Comic Con
is not a name anymore I guess honor and
that was a lot of fun
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I got a little nervous being up on stage
in front of what looked to be a few
thousand people in the crowd and I
forgot the black hood that was supposed
to go under the helmet like a complete
idiot so you can see my red hair pouring
out the sides like a Batgirl cowl other
than that it was okay I've met a lot of
far more talented craftsmen who built
bigger and better armor but I think this
was solid for my first try all of us
lost to the guy who showed up in the
power loader from alien so I guess we're
all an equal footing on just being
jealous of that guy then the other prize
went to mrs. Doubtfire because funny and
cute wins more points with judges than
you know Talent I'm not bitter your bear
shut up I never in a million years
thought I could conceive and build
something this complicated in just two
weeks but I really surprised myself with
this cosplay maybe the lesson to take
away is that you shouldn't hold back
because of self-doubt if you have
something you want to try give it a shot
and you might just be pretty good at it
for no reason at all expand your
horizons try new things
boycott EI for killing his franchise oh
my god I could talk for days about why
dead space 3 ruined my childhood what an
insult that was the absolute worst thing
to happen in 2013 and I got attacked by
a pit bull that year if you want me to
make it to our video about why Dead
Space 3 is bad just leave a comment
asking for more spider-man content
awesome thanks for your support I'll
write it right away bye just a quick
reminder before you go that I post my
videos a day early on patreon and give
exclusive behind-the-scenes content and
patron exclusive videos please consider
becoming a patron it really helps me out
if you want a more short-term way to
support the channel you can check out my
merch and the links in the description
we have t-shirts phone cases posters
mugs pillows baby onesies and so much
more see you next time
[Music]
[Music]